book TV Harry Potter and the Prisoner of
Azkaban is the latest in JK Rowling
series of books about the boy wizard in
a moment we'll hear from his Rowling at
the National Press Club in Washington DC
but first here's a reading from her
first book Harry Potter and the
Sorcerer's Stone
Walter Mays is acting the part of Harry
Potter's friend Hagrid she's a ravenclaw
very good
welcome Harry Potter books don't you or
Hagrid and what we're doing here is this
is the Sorting Hat and the sorting hat
knows which house you belong in in the
house at Hogwarts Wow Slytherin
hufflepuff
there's Raven floor in this Gryffindor
and what we do who would like to choose
from the story head you've done it
already Missy we're like have you done a
come here
we just put the hat over her head do you
want to turn the face of camera miss
there you go would you put the hat over
her head that's going to get a sense of
who she eats and now closing your eyes
and not peeking reach inside pick your
tag alizarin it's a ravenclaw she's a
Ravenclaw and it's a little sticker you
want it on okay
run your jacket right there thank you
very much who wants to step up come hear
me on this all right reach inside reach
inside she's got a ravenclaw excellent
tried to go miss would you write
inside very good a Hufflepuff all right
I'm going to start doing some stories
now ladies and gentlemen I'm Hagrid hold
on a minute miss if you stick around
I'm Hagrid from the Harry Potter books
and what I'm going to do is I'm going to
do a reading from the first book which
is Harry Potter and the Sorcerer's Stone
all on set
see
you're right that's not the one
thank you
this is chapter floor from Harry Potter
and the Sorcerer's Stone this is called
the keeper of the keys
they knocked again Dudley jerked awake
where's the cannon he said stupidly
there was a crash behind him and Uncle
Vernon came skidding into the room he
was holding a rifle in his hands and now
they knew what had been in that long
thin package he had brought with them
who's there shall I warn you I'm armed
there was a pause then smash the door
was hit with such force that it swung
clean off its hinges and with a
deafening crash landed flat on the floor
a giant of a man was standing in the
doorway as me his face was almost
completely hidden by a long shaggy mane
of hair I'm eating myself up a bit since
then and a wild tangled beard but she
could make out his eyes glinting like
black beetles under all the hair the joy
had squeezed his way into the hut
stooping so that his head just brushed
the ceiling he bent down picked up the
door and fitted it easily back into the
frame the noise of the storm outside
dropped a little and he turned to look
at them all couldn't make us are covered
here Georgia it's not been an easy
journey he's
strode over to the sofa where Dudley sat
frozen with fear Barjatya great lump
said the stranger
Dudley squeaked and ran to hide behind
his mother who was crouching terrified
behind Uncle Vernon and here's Harry
said the giant Harry looked up into the
fierce wild shadowy face and saw that
the beetle eyes were crinkled in a
little smile last time I saw you it was
only a baby said the giant you look a
lot like your dad but you've got your
mum's eyes Uncle Vernon made a funny
rasping noise I I demand that you leave
at once sir he said you are breaking and
entering oh shut up Dursley you great
prune said the Giant he reached over the
back of the sofa jerked the going out
uncle Vernon's hands big didn't you
ignored as easily as if it had been made
of rubber and threw it into the corner
of the room Uncle Vernon made another
funny noise like a mouse being trodden
on anyway Harry said the giant turning
his back on the Dursleys a very happy
birthday to you got summat for you here
I might have sat on it at some point but
it'll taste alright from an inside
pocket of his black overcoat he pulled a
slightly squashed box
Harry opened him with trembling fingers
inside was a large sticky chocolate cake
with happy birthday Harry written in
green icing Harry looked up at the Giant
he meant to say thank you but the words
got lost on the way to his mouth and
what he said instead was who are you the
giant chuckled
or true I haven't introduced myself
Rubeus Hagrid keeper of keys and grounds
at Hogwarts
he held out his enormous hand and shook
Harry's whole arm well what about their
teeth and he said I'll not say no to
summon stronger if you've got it in mind
and his eyes fell on the empty great
with the shriveled chip bags in it and
he snorted he bent down over the
fireplace they couldn't see what he was
doing but when he drew back a second
later there was a roaring fire there it
filled the whole damp Hut with
flickering light and Harry felt the
warmth wash over him as though he'd sunk
into a hot bath the giant sat back down
on the sofa which sagged under his
weight and he began taking all sorts of
things out of the pockets of his coat a
copper kettle a squashy package of
sausages a poker a teapot several chip
mugs and a bottle of some amber liquid
he took a swig from before starting to
make tea
soon the hunt was full of the sound of
the smell a sizzling sausage nobody said
a thing while the giant was working but
as he slid the first six fat juicy
slightly burnt sausages from the poker
godly fidgeted a little Uncle Vernon
said sharply don't touch anything he
gives you Dudley the Giant chuckled
darkly ah your great pudding of a son
don't need fattening any more Dursley
don't you worry and he passed the
sausages to Harry who was so hungry he
had never tasted anything so wonderful
but he still couldn't take his eyes off
the Giant the Harry Potter series made
news last week when various articles
appeared in national newspapers on the
front page of the New York Times Jodie
will goron wrote about the objection of
some parents to the wizardry in the book
says anti-religious she detailed a
crusade to have the books banned at many
elementary schools later in the week
columnist EJ Dionne wrote in The
Washington Post his opinion that the
children's book has good moral
foundations allegorized in a fantastic
setting
JK Rowling addresses both these views at
a speech at the National Press Club in
Washington DC where she appeared two
weeks ago this discussion lasts about
half an hour and is followed by a book
signing
hi I'm Shawn Bullard I am the chairman
of the book and author committee here at
the National Press Club I want to thank
everyone for coming out today
it's greatly appreciated I see that
there are a lot of kids here out in the
balcony playing hooky today and if you
need a explanation for your teacher
Larry Lippmann the president of the
Press Club is a very good writer
following custom I will introduce our
guest she will then offer us some
magical insight into her new book Harry
Potter and the Prisoner of Azkaban and
then I would like to encourage those of
you who have questions to point print
them on the index cards provided at each
table and then pass them forward
following questions I will wrap up the
event promptly so that our guest has
time to sign books and I believe also to
catch a plane please please please be
respective of this fact we are going to
allow one signed book per person at the
very beginning and if there is time
allowed we will then sign additional
books but please she needs to be out of
here
by two o'clock today and finally I would
like to remind you of next week's book
and author wrap at the National Press
Club on the evening of October the 26th
the book and author committee will
present the new new thing a Silicon
Valley story by Michael Lewis a while
ago I read in the New York Times that
Harry Potter was destined for greatness
forgive me for my ignorance but earlier
this year had no idea who Harry Potter
was my wife and I had twins about five
months ago I did know one thing JK
Rowling and her young wizard with the
lightning bolts car was taking America
by storm whether on the train to work in
the bookstore on the phone with my 12
year old nephew everyone was raving
about this be speckled kid named Harry
Potter I kid you not recently a complete
stranger on the train begged me to
his business card and get a signed by
our guests so that he could give it to
his son and I do have it in my pocket
and it is signed so that PR executive
from New Jersey will have it in the mail
in the next couple of days it's only
appropriate that is if by magic Harry
Potter seems to have appeared out of
nowhere it is if one day we were without
the centuries-old Hogwarts School of
Witchcraft and Wizardry
and the next America couldn't imagine
life without Harry Potter and as if
having over five million books and
circulation isn't enough and both kids
and adults clamoring for her books our
guest has captured the Triple Crown of
publishing Harry Potter and the
Sorcerer's Stone Harry Potter and the
Chamber of Secrets and today's book have
rocketed to the top three bestseller
slots in recent weeks in short Harry
Potter's hocus pocus has catapulted our
guests near legendary status ladies and
gentlemen I present to you best-selling
children's author winner of rave reviews
on both sides of the Atlantic and
creator of Harry Potter JK Rowling
thank you very much thank you very much
really wonderful to be here I'm going to
do a short reading for you and then take
questions I like them best I'm sorry I
know you're the people I like them best
I'm playing to the gallery today and so
a brief reading now I am actually going
to do a reading from the first book
Sorcerer's Stone there's a very
practical reason for this I have a good
short reading in this one and we don't
have that much time I really would like
to spend the time answering questions I
think that would be better so this is
the moment when Harry buys his most
important piece of equipment for
Hogwarts School of Witchcraft and
Wizardry which is of course his wand
what else this is what happens in the
wand shop
Harry has gone there with Hagrid who is
one of my favorite characters you know
the giant gamekeeper from the school and
he's about to meet mr. Ollivander the
famed wand maker
good afternoon said a soft voice Harry
jumped Hagrid must have jumped too
because there was loud crunching noise
and he Cooke got quickly off the spindly
chair an old man was standing before
them his white pale eyes shining like
moons through the gloom of the shop
hello said Harry awkwardly
ah yes said the man yes yes I thought
I'd be seeing you soon Harry Potter it
wasn't a question you have your mother's
eyes it seems only yesterday she was in
here herself buying her first wand 10
and a quarter inches long
swishy made of willow nice one for charm
work mr. Ollivander moved closer to
Harry Harry wished he would blink those
silvery eyes were a bit creepy
your father on the other hand favoured a
mahogany wand 11 inches pliable a little
more power and excellent for
Transfiguration well I say your father
favored it it's really the wand that
chooses the wizard of course mr.
Ollivander had come so close that he and
Harry were almost nose-to-nose Harry
could see himself reflected in those
misty eyes and that's where mr.
Ollivander touched the lightning scar on
Harry's forehead with a long white
finger I'm sorry to say I sold the wand
that did it
he
softly 13 and a half inches you powerful
wand very powerful and in the wrong
hands well if I'd known what that wand
was going out into the world to do he
shook his head and then to Harry's
relief spotted Hagrid Roubaix Ezra
Bayers Hagrid how nice to see you again
oke sixteen inches rather bendy wasn't
it it was sir yes said Hagrid good wand
that one but I suppose they snapped it
in half when he got expelled said mr.
Ollivander suddenly Stern oh yes they
did yes said Hagrid shuffling his feet
I've got the pieces though he added
brightly but you don't use them said Mr
Ollivander sharply oh no sir said Hagrid
quickly
Harry noticed he gripped his pink
umbrella very tightly as he spoke hmm
said Mr Ollivander giving Hagrid a
piercing look well now mr. Potter let me
see
he pulled a long tape measure with
silver markings out of his pocket which
is your wand on all I'm right-handed
said Harry hold out your arm that's it
he measured Harry from shoulder to
finger then wrist to elbow shoulder to
floor need to armpit and round his head
as he measured he said every Ollivander
wand has a core of a powerful magics
magical substance mr. Potter we use
unicorn hairs Phoenix tail feathers and
the heartstrings of dragons no to Oliver
Ollivander wands are the same just as no
two unicorns dragons or Phoenix's are
quite the same and of course you will
never get such good results with another
Wizards wand Harry suddenly realized
that the tape measure which was
measuring between his nostrils was doing
this on its own mr. Ollivander was
flitting around the shelves taking down
boxes that will do he said and the tape
measure crumpled into a heap on the
floor right then mr. Potter try this one
beechwood and dragon heartstring
9 inches nice and flexible just take it
and give it a wave Harry took the wand
and feeling foolish waved it around a
bit but Mr Ollivander snatched it out of
his hand almost at once maple and
phoenix feather 7 inches quite whippy
try harry tried but he had hardly raised
the wand when it too was snatched back
by mr. Ollivander
no no here Eponine
corn hair eight and a half inches
springy go on go on try it out Harry
tried and tried he had no idea what mr.
Ollivander was waiting for the pile of
tried ones was mounting higher and
higher on the spindly chair but the more
ones mr. Ollivander pulled from the
shells the happier he seemed to become
tricky customer eh not to worry we'll
find the perfect match here somewhere I
wonder now yes why not unusual
combination holly and phoenix feather 11
inches nice and supple harry took the
wand he felt a sudden warmth in his
fingers he raised the wand above his
head brought it swishing down through
the dusty air and a stream of red and
gold sparks shot from the end like a
firework throwing dancing spots of light
onto the walls Hagrid whooped and
clapped and mr. Ollivander cried Oh
Bravo yes indeed a very good well well
well
how curious how very curious
he put Harry's wand back into its box
and wrapped it in brown paper still
muttering curious curious sorry said
Harry but what's curious mr. Ollivander
fixed Harry with his pale stare I
remember every wand I've ever sold mr.
Potter every single wand it so happens
that the Phoenix whose tail feather is
in your wand gave another feather just
one other it is very curious indeed that
you should be destined for this wand
when it's brother why it's brother gave
you that scar
okay right we're doing questions yes you
know it sounds so much better when
you're reading it the first question did
you write the book for children or
adults and I wrote it for me
so both because I wrote something that I
knew I would like to read now but I also
wrote something that I knew I would have
liked to have read at age 10 so I I
never really wrote with them with anyone
in mind
I still don't write with an imaginary
focus group in mind I have been asked
time without number why are the books so
popular and the true and I don't want to
analyze that I don't I don't want to
decide that there's a formula I really
don't want to look at that too closely
because I want to carry on writing them
the way I want to write them and not you
know start trying to put ingredient X in
there it's a is for other people to
decide that not me I think several have
asked how did you come up with Quidditch
oh quit it the irony of me inventing a
sport I managed to break my arm playing
netball which as you know is not a
famous contact sport I decided that if
the Wizards had this whole secret
society thing going on I was thinking of
things that unify a society and I
decided that one thing would have to be
a sport and that would be an opportunity
for the Wizards to meet in secret and
all you know congregate together it
would just be too difficult for them to
congregate watch baseball or something
we'd notice they dead upset they fire
their wands off and stuff in the crowd
that wouldn't work so they had to have
their own sport so and I had a lot of
fun making up the rules of Quidditch
it's a violent and dangerous game and
I'd be appalling at it but it's fun to
think about
when did you start writing the books and
I start I had the idea for Harry in 1990
so I've now been writing about him for
nine years and by the time I finished
the seven books I'll have been writing
about him for 13 years so and that will
is going to feel like a bereavement I
know that already when I write the end
on book 7 it's going to be a really I'm
going to be heartbroken but that's what
I planned and that's what I'm going to
do so where do you get the inspiration
well if I knew I'd go and live there but
I have no idea I get asked that a lot
I know sometimes I have to say well
where do you get your ideas from and
it's room the problem with turning it
round like that is sometimes people know
so that one doesn't work you think
you're being really clever doing that
well here's what inspire know so in
truth most of the ideas just come some I
have to work hard for some of them
normally it's a process kind of twisted
logic ideas like platform 9 and 3/4 I
wanted it to be a secret place in a real
station and if you follow that thought
through you you think hidden platform
and if you follow that thought through
it's got to be between two real
platforms and you end up with a fraction
and I just picked 9 and 3/4 because it
sounded like a you know cool number
that's so you know sometimes I remember
the thought process I followed to get
somewhere but other things just do just
pop up several have asked about the
movie right the position that where we
are on the movie is the script is nearly
finished director should be chosen by
the end of the year the film should be
ready summer of 2001 they're telling me
so I can't wait to see Quidditch
oh that's the bit I'm really really
looking forward to seeing I've told them
that they grinned nervously can you
imagine Harry ever growing up and always
you see I have this here
for five years I was writing about Harry
and I never spoke about it to anyone
except my sister I told her the story of
the first book but she'd never read it
so all this stuff is going on in my head
so it's such an incredible thing for me
now to be somewhere like this and for
people to be interested in talking about
it because I didn't have that
opportunity at all for five or six years
but the frustrating thing is I can't
tell you stuff because it will ruin the
rest of the books so I'm going to have
to pass on that question because I do
know exactly what's going to happen to
Harry in book seven but I'm not going to
tell you this one is obviously from one
of our guests in the peanut gallery
there because it's X doubt words and
letters but it says have you written
your next book question mark
what happens next please tell me I think
you should be very offended by that
peanut gallery remark frankly and my
book for is I'm going to be finishing it
when I get home it's a it's not too far
off completion I do know what happens
and I'm not going to tell you that
either
and I'm trying to think of something I
can you see the Quidditch World Cup in
book 4 which is Ireland versus Bulgaria
which I like England got knocked out by
Transylvania which is a bit upsetting
and I actually said this in Scotland
this boy put up his hand and said what
happened to Scotland I said well you
were slaughtered by Luxembourg and he
wasn't happy they take it really soon
but Luxembourg are rubbish how do you
know what they're like a Quidditch and
yeah so you see that but if you if you
saw on the Internet because evil wizards
have infiltrated the internet and put on
their but the title of book 4 is Harry
Potter and the Quidditch World Cup and
that's not true they're just messing
with your mind it's not true at all but
I'm not going to tell you the title
because I'm a bit superstitious about
that I like to keep the secret until the
books finished one of our teachers has
asked my students and I wonder if there
are any significance to you signing your
book with just your initials yeah this
is a funny one that wasn't my choice
when I finished my um my copy of the
manuscript I put Joanne Rowling on there
that being my name and all and then my
publisher my British publisher phoned me
up two months before the first book was
published and said we'd like you to use
your initials and I said and to be frank
I would have let them call me Enid
Snodgrass if they published the book so
I really really wasn't that bothered
with this either my gratitude was such
that sighs did okay fine but why and
they said first of all they said we
think it looks more striking and I said
why really and they said well we think
boys will like this book we're not sure
that they'd pick it up if they think a
woman wrote
and the funny thing is that it was
completely pointless thing to do because
two months after the book was published
I was on national television and I
wasn't wearing a false beard or anything
so everyone now knows that I'm a well
everyone that I met I've met no one's
gone where is he
it's me and no one seems remotely but
bothered which i think is really
encouraging so that's why it was my
British publisher so write and yell at
them not me
one of our young visitors asked do you
have any imaginary friends and who are
they well you know them they see they're
in here please that's who they are
I did have the imaginary friends when I
was younger I think a lot of children do
I had a very vivid fantasy life I think
when I was a child which is not uncommon
spit-up worrying that maybe that I
didn't outgrow it better but yeah I
think I always will have no I don't have
imaginary friends now in the sense that
I'm pretending someone called peewee is
standing next to me no no I don't what
advice would you give to young people
who have an interest in writing and also
to their parents and I often get asked
by younger readers what I would advise
if you want to be a writer this is the
way I did it so that's the only advice I
can give you've got to read as much as
you possibly can because that's the best
way to recognize good writing and to
learn what makes bad writing and those
are very good things you'll probably go
through a phase where you imitate your
favorite writers that's perfectly okay
that's another learning process you
resign yourself to writing lots and lots
of rubbish you just got to write that
out of your system and sooner or later
you'll hit what you know you really
should be doing and what is your genre
and perseverance you've got to persevere
because it is a it's a career with a lot
of knock backs but the rewards are huge
I don't mean in the sense that if that's
what you really want to do to be able to
do it life long is the best thing in the
world very rewarding but it's not a
career for people who are easily
discouraged that's for sure and
to their parents don't tell them it's
unrealistic never to never say that
because even if they're not published
writing
well writing is the passion of my life
so it's an important thing to do you
probably should read this one because
they're asking how to pronounce oh yeah
II friends names this is the question I
get asked more than any other and I'm
starting to wish I'd called her Jane
what is the girl who is Harry who is
Harry's friend's name her my oh me
Hermione
her Moines is really common I hear that
a lot but my favorite ones still her me
one and the wicked part of me when I
heard her me one wanted to say that's
exactly right well done but there I
thought that was too cruel because one
of these kids would grow up and name
their child her me one so we didn't want
that so it's Hermione next one is how
did you come up with her name and it
just seemed to suit her somehow it's a
name from Shakespeare it's in The
Winter's Tale
she although my Hermione bears very
little relation to that Hermione but it
just seen the sort of name that a pair
of professional dentists who like to
prove how clever they were do you know
what I mean gave their daughter a nice
unusual name that no one could pronounce
I mean parents do that and I did want in
in truth I wanted quite an unusual name
for her because I think there are quite
a lot of girls like Hermione I was girl
like Hermione and I it crossed my mind
as I was writing without ever knowing
that I would even be published that if I
ever was published I didn't want to give
her a common name you know just in case
somewhere out there there was a Jane
with big front teeth who was really
sweaty and annoying just thought just
thought that might not be a good idea
why is a HIPAA graph a half eagle and a
half horse
why is a Hippogriff a half eagle and
waffles I didn't invent a Hippogriff
Peter medieval European people genuinely
believed they existed we won't go into
the reasons that might be
but it's a mythical creature it's an
unusual mythical creature it's not as
famous as a unicorn or ax or a Griffin
so I don't really know you'd have to ask
the medieval monks who did those
beautiful illuminations and they drew
them on their I'll I'm very fond of my
Hippogriff
I like Buckbeak if you've read book 3
you'll know who that is if you haven't
then that will be gobbledygook to you so
sorry several people have asked are you
stopping at seven at the moment I think
I'm going to stop at seven and as I say
that will be really heartbreaking
the only reason you'll ever see an
eighth Harry Potter book is if I really
in ten years time burn to do another one
but at the moment I think that's
unlikely but I try never to say never
about anything at the moment I say I
will never I do it next month so I did I
but I think not I think we're going to
stop at seven how many points does
Quidditch have how many has he played up
to someone's obviously keeping score oh
I see no I understand
okay you infinity you can go on forever
because it says in book one the longest
ever match went on for about three
months continuously so that was a lot of
points so you you you never stop at a
certain amount of points the only thing
that can stop a Quidditch match is the
Golden Snitch being called and if no one
catches the snitch you can keep playing
for years
well she seemed alright but she was
quite sadistic did Voldemort go to
school with Lily and James Lily and
James being Harry's parents no Baltimore
is quite a bit older than them he was at
school with Hagrid Hagrid it's quite
Hagrid doesn't seem that old but he's in
fact in his sixties but he's just you
know he's a strong man so he doesn't
seem that old so Valda more and that
kind of age what other books would you
recommend for a nine-year-old um oh
loads of books anything by Philip
Pullman of modern writers there's a book
called Skellig by an English author
David Armand which i think is absolutely
magnificent stuff I enjoyed when I was a
child I loved Ynez bit his she's I'd
really like to see a comeback of he
Nesbit's works I think she was a genius
um what else
Paul gallico he's he's out of print a
lot now and I really loved his work to
any of those people why in the first
book does Harry's lightning scar flash
or when when he gets his lightning scar
flash when snap looks at him Snape Snape
okay now this is a I have a problem as
well he's sleep-deprived he's got five
month old twins and and if anyone hasn't
finished reading book one will they
please put their fingers really tightly
in their ears now if they don't want the
ending ruined really tightly now because
this is a question about the ending snip
Quirrell had the back of his head too
hairy at the point when Harry looked at
Snape so someone else was looking at
Harry through a certain turban see what
I mean if you've read it you understand
if you haven't read it you're going what
but that's okay we're going to take a
few more questions and the next one is
will Harry ever turn into a shape
changer like his father no Harry's not
in training to be an animagus if you
unless you've read book three you won't
know that's the wizard that is very very
difficult to do they learn to turn
themselves into animals no Harry is not
Harry's energies are going to be
concentrate
elsewhere he's not gonna have time to do
that he's got quite a full agenda coming
up poor poor boy very good one more
question
are we going to learn more about Harry's
mom in the next book this is one of
those questions see these some of the
best questions I get are about people
have clearly read the book so well and
they're sensing that there's more to be
told about certain people but I can't
ever answer them very fully because I
will end up giving things away there is
something very important about Harry's
mother that he hasn't yet discovered but
he's not going to find her out in the
next book it's too important for a book
for it he finds it out later in the
series that was interesting I'm going to
ask one more there were a lot of groans
when I said we were going to wrap it up
so one more what happened to Harry's
grandparents um various interesting
things but again I'm not going to share
sorry but that's okay because we have
time for another question so I didn't
answer that one oh good it's a good
excuse to write more books true yes um
is there anything that you'd want to add
no I think one more question because we
didn't really get an answer to that very
good no tell me that one oh I like this
one do Harry and Hermione have a date no
they have their very platonic friends
but I won't answer for anyone else
nudge-nudge wink-wink
we want to thank our guests thank you
very much
and also want to thank all of you for
coming also the children who came we
also want to present our guests with the
prestigious National Press Club mug
thank you very much I will treasure it
always
thank you and we also want to thank
press club staff Laura phallosan ski Pat
Nelson Melanie Dermott for organizing
today's lunch and thank all of you again
for coming thank you please make sure
that you respect the number that you
were given at the door when coming to
have your book signed we certainly do
not want to mob her like she has been
mobbed in the past couple of days thank
you thank you
thank you hi I think this book man I
think that it's not good but they make
decisions on behalf of other people's
children
thank you so much oh yes he's back there
in the little tennis where did you go
and thank you so much my agent
where's the tennis where
6ue Oh any chapter page 118 is Breton
evening
yeah how's this or sorcerers oh just um
tell them that I go to I will
thank you thank you congratulations
wonderful thank you thank you very much
thanks a lot
because I can
they know
thanks a lot
thank you thank you
experiment
Oh
oh wow
thank
thank you so much no problem thank you
thank you very much pleasure to hear
your today thanks very much
here you go honey thank you
thank you
hey I know problem thank you I know
very much
I think the big fan thank all thanks a
lot
thank you
and many more to make sure everyone gets
at least one side bhai it's a production
line many works
thank you very much for taking the time
to do it really enjoyed it thank you
very much much - enjoy - okay fine fine
hi thank you you put them up
ah
all right
121 up to 140
I
love you thank you very much thank you
thank you
to get there
sorry
I
Murphy kidney Hey thank you I thank you
very much
116i
thank you
it's an old
Oh
flexible
Ginger's question I like that one I was
with her thank you
cause you better ride at the airport hi
sorry it right there or not I got a ride
thank you
that was my question inside
favorite boys named Harry thank you
thank you place along
thank you
way to do that
all right we're just trying to get there
yeah thank you sorry yeah you did 122
122 yeah just go back around okay
remember the first one do
he goes thank you thank you wonderful
thank you
thank you very much
thank you very much for my daughter for
you thumbs up she and I can even read
that which is really good thank you very
much
hi oh yeah
I thought you look familiar
I
thank you everywhere and explains
everything that's in here how's it going
gasps are you okay when you tell her the
winning in that Scotland
all right back to its design I got two
week to finish very thanks very much no
you haven't
it's exciting yeah
thank you
last night
who do you think I would miss this
thank you very much was delightful
thank you
thank you
here you any idea how many numbers are
STL I think she loved you any idea how
many never librarian you've done a great
gift for this case so nice to hear very
much
thank you
very much
thank you and New Statesman come here my
skinhead boy is it confidently expecting
the part in the movie
I need to say that one's for you yeah
yeah I left my token here what do you
think you can have that one Mike oh
that's just a will only people who bring
me 5 volts get person ice but this is my
thank you very much Stephen asking
Jessica Linscott
thank you very much it's good to talk
huh
thanks a lot
thank you
everyone
thank you
thank you
thank you just amazing thank you thanks
very much
okay but stay around
yeah okay mr. ground yeah
thank you very much best of luck thank
you
thank you bye son Katarina best thing I
can have like you can see
thank you very much
taking it go thanks a lot
thank you so much thank you very much
we are you know meet you when you're
famous you'll say we met first time here
thank you very much
your back it's getting it [ __ ]
thank you
thank you very much thanks a lot
I'm back
remember
thanks the box it's a real treat a
seven-year-old just wrote you a quick
letter about Bogaerts I really yes he
had a good coin hahaha you know what
girl
thank you
thank you
thank you thank you
thank you thank you
I
yeah
thank you very much
- indeed this morning thanks very much
that was great thank you the folks have
changed missing his life Abid she's now
average from an average reader that much
thing in the world it's been terrific
for you so
the manuscript you turn in for the first
book nearly identical what was pulling
seeing everybody thank you so much thank
you and sorry mo
I can't frame
you're
sorry I'm not allowed to do that
sometimes everyone
I feel so sorry for your hand boy are
you okay it's getting a nice long breath
thank you very much thank you there you
go thank you very much
thank you but you're like America very
much in Daisy
but you do very good
we begin with
to do
whoo
thank you
nice like your cool
thank you
we should be less to replace them first
secondary which cooks best to be first
yeah the first way is definitely
thank you
backwards
thank you
would you like a hand massage here we go
what do I do now
okay stop here come this way
okay stand right there thank you very
much yeah thank you
maybe watching for you thank you very
much
JK Rowling's books hold three of the top
four spots on this week's New York Times
bestselling fiction list this book Harry
Potter and the Prisoner of Azkaban is
published by Scholastic Press